with at least one in 100 children in the
us born with a congenital heart defect
each year las vegas is coming together
to honor the champions that are fighting
against what can be a deadly pediatric
disease melissa cipriano the executive
director of the children's heart
foundation is here to tell us more hello
thank you for coming what you guys do is
absolutely incredible and this is going
to be the fourth annual charity event
tell us a little bit about it the hearts
for charity is a time that we can come
together and honor our philanthropist of
the year but most importantly raise a
little bit of awareness and much needed
funding for our foundations so we can
provide services the children's heart
foundation it really is a life-changing
organization tell us a little bit about
what you do
well we help families while they're
going through a medical crisis with
their child and so
you know some of our families they know
before their child is born that they
will have a congenital heart defect
others
they have heart episodes later on in
life
and
what we do is we help those families
during a medical crisis so if a child is
going in for surgery that you know
there's it affects their family income
because somebody has to take time off of
work we help with that financial
assistance we help with gas cards and
maybe paying a utility or a little help
with rent or what have you and then we
also help with travel a lot of our
families have to come in from rural
areas of nevada or from reno and we help
with those travel costs as well now this
event that you guys are having tell us a
little bit about where it is how people
get tickets it sounds like a lot of fun
it's a lot of fun it's just a it's a fun
afternoon to you know join with some of
your favorite friends and you know honor
our little heart heroes in our community
and it's at the four seasons fun yeah
they nobody does tea better than the
four seasons no we're not that is great
and how do people get tickets if they
want to be a part of this tickets are
still available on our website if you go
to chfn.org
just click on the hearts for charity tab
and i'll take you right into our ticket
uh our ticket
purchase system that we have okay and
we're gonna have a silent auction we've
got some uh live auction items and
there's gonna be some heart heroes there
that you get to meet so i love that and
not only does the money go to help these
families but also
camp mendahart tell us a little bit
about that well camp mendehart is
nevada's heart camp for children ages 7
to 17 years of age and this past year we
were able to take them to california to
pathfinder ranch and it's a time where
heart patients are able to be themselves
they don't have to explain a way why
they're tired or explain away their
scars they get to be with like-minded
friends to create memories to learn from
one another and to foster their
independence all while you know doing
great
great fun activities at camp just seeing
their faces light up when they 100 free
for our families and so that's why we
need to raise money thank you so much
make sure you check out the event and
put some smiles on some kids faces
kendall